y se habla de posibles distanciamientos
de rupturas al interior de esa coalición
peronista que tan dividida puede estar o
qué tan afectada internamente puede
estar después de los comicios del
domingo
pero a la luz de los acontecimientos de
las últimas horas están surgiendo
claramente divisiones fracturas
disidencias dentro de la colección de
gobierno particularmente en cómo
interpretar la derrota electoral del
domingo el pasado y con cuál debe ser la
reacción del gobierno frente a esa
derrota el sector liderado por la
vicepresidenta cristina kirchner está
reclamando cambios en el equipo de
gobierno del presidente del presidente
está resistiendo esos cambios y eso fue
lo que motivó que la mayoría de los
funcionarios que responden a la
vicepresidenta presentarán su renuncia a
disposición del presidente todavía
desconocemos cuál va a ser la decisión
final del presidente
el señor romero este remezón ministerial
qué significa para el presidente
fernández después de la derrota en las
paso cómo está la imagen del presidente
con este tema y del gobierno argentino
en general con esta coyuntura
bueno es interesante la pregunta porque
para entender la dimensión de la derrota
hay que comprender que la argentina
venía sufriendo una crisis del día de la
legitimidad del ente el liderazgo
presidencial de un presidente que ha
estado muy golpeado en términos de
imagen por la gestión sanitaria pero
también por la mala gestión económica y
que hace poco más de un mes atrás tuvo
un episodio de escándalo cuando se
conocieron fotos del presidente
celebrando el cumpleaños de su primera
de su esposa de la primera dama en el
medio de la cuarentena estricta que el
gobierno decidió para defenderse de la
pandemia ese escándalo produjo un
impacto negativo en la imagen del
presidente y en parte explica la derrota
electoral sufrida por la coalición
gobernante por eso decimos que el
resultado profundizó esa crisis del
liderazgo presidencial y ahora el
presidente al frente al desafío de
reestructurar su gobierno para empezar a
dar respuestas y poder recuperar en algo
la imagen pública señor romero a toda
esta serie de hechos que usted nos está
mencionando que anteceden este remezón
ministerial más este remezón más las
elecciones
las primarias las paso como puede ser
aprovechado o como ha sido ya
aprovechado por la oposición para
fortalecerse porque ustedes están en
argentina en año electoral tienen las
legislativas en noviembre
si claramente la oposición la principal
coalición opositora juntos por el cambio
ha salido triunfadora de la elección
primaria del domingo pasado y allí la
atención está centrada en las
principales figuras porque claramente de
esta elección legislativa de medio
término van a salir las principales
figuras que aspiran a ser digamos el
candidato a presidente en 2023 de la
coalición opositora así resaltan la
figura de horacio rodríguez larreta que
es el jefe de gobierno de la ciudad de
buenos aires la capital de argentina y
algunas figuras del radicalismo que es
el otro partido que integra la coalición
opositora del resultado de noviembre van
a quedar perfilado los dirigentes
opositores que tendrán la posibilidad de
pensar que en el 2023 la coalición
opositora se vuelva y se transforme en
gobierno habrá que ver cómo resuelve el
desafío económico este actual gobierno
porque le quedan dos años de mandato y
el desafío económico es muy importante